THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAMMERING DEMOCRATS WITH A STERN
MID-TERM MESSAGE.
>> President Trump: COME
ELECTION DAY, AMERICANS WILL
REMEMBER KAVANAUGH AND THEY WILL
REMEMBER ALL SORTS OF OTHER
THINGS, BECAUSE THAT WAS A
SHAMEFUL ACT.
THIS WILL BE AN ELECTION OF
KAVANAUGH, THE CARAVAN, LAW AND
ORDER, AND COMMON SENSE.
BUT THE CHOICE COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR, DEMOCRATS PRODUCE MOBS.
REPUBLICANS PRODUCE JOBS.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS DON'T SEEM
TO BE ABLE TO GET ON THE SAME
PAGE.
FOR EXAMPLE, TEXAS SENATE
HOPEFUL BETO O'ROARKE IS
DOUBLING DOWN ON IMPEACHING
TRUMP.
>> I WOULD LIKEN IMPEACHMENT TO
AN INDICTMENT.
THERE IS ENOUGH THERE TO PROCEED
WITH A TRIAL FOR A FULL VETTING
OF THE FACTS, AND MAKES THE BEST
INFORMED DECISION IN THE
INTERESTS OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND OUR FUTURE.
>> Jesse: SENATOR SPARTACUS,
COREY BOOKER, MAKING THIS
BIZARRE CLAIM, CANADA IS MORE
AMERICAN THAN AMERICA.
>> EVERY COUNTRY WE ARE
COMPETING WITH, IS DRIVING DOWN
THE COST OF COLLEGE.
GERMANY COST IS 0 AND 4% MEDIAN
INCOME GOING TO COLLEGE.
CANADA, I CAN'T STAND HOW
AMERICAN CANADA IS, TRUDEAU,
HE'S GREAT.
COST ABOUT 6% OR 7% OF MEDIAN
INCOME FOR COLLEGE.
IN AMERICA 5, 2% MEDIAN INCOME.
WHY ARE OTHER NATION MORE
AMERICAN?
>> Jesse: AND NANCY PELOSI,
EXPLAINING WHY SHE DOESN'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT SOCIALIST
POLICIES HURT AMERICANS.
>> I THINK THAT WE OWE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO BE THERE FOR
THEM, FOR THEIR FINANCIAL
SECURITY, RESPECTING THE DIGNITY
AND WORK OF EVERY PERSON IN THAT
COUNTRY.
AND IF THERE'S SOME COLLATERAL
DAMAGE, FOR OTHERS WHO DO NOT
SHARE OUR VIEW, SO BE IT.
BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE OUR ORIGINAL
PURPOSE.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, DANA,
SMORGAS BORG OF DEMOCRATIC --
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO GRASP AT
ANYTHING TO GET THE MESSAGE
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Dana: TWO OF THOSE, COREY
BOOKER AND BETO O'ROARKE ARE
RUNNING FOR 2020.
NANCY PELOSI PROBABLY THE MOST
MESSAGE DISCIPLINED, REMEMBER
SHE'S THE ONE SAYING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IMPEACHMENT,
EVERYBODY STOP THAT, BETO
O'ROARKE IS ACTUALLY, SAYING
THAT AN INDICTMENT AND
IMPEACHMENT ARE THE SAME THING.
WHICH IS JUST LEGALLY NOT TRUE.
AND HE SHOULD KNOW THAT IF HE'S
RUNNING FOR SENATE.
I THINK IF HE ENDS UP LOSING IN
TEXAS, YOU WILL SEE HIM ON ALL
OF THE SHOWS FOR THE NEXT WEEK,
WHERE THE HOST WILL BEG HIM TO
RUN IN 2020.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN.
THAT IS NOT A STRONG MESSAGE.
COREY BOOKER, WHERE IS HE GIVING
IN A SPEECH?
IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
IS HE IN SOUTH CAROLINA?
HE'S HELPING CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE WANTING TO --
CHALLENGERS TO REPUBLICANS, THEY
WANT TO WIN.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING IN SOUTH
CAROLINA.
UNLIKE LINDSAY GRAY MAM, FOR
EXAMPLE, GOING OUT ON A 12-STATE
TOUR AFTER KAVANAUGH SO HE CAN
DO ALL THOSE THINGS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HIS CLOSING
ARGUMENT IS GOING TO BE
KAVANAUGH, THE CARAVAN, LAW AND
ORDER AND COMMON SENSE.
2 1/2 WEEKS UNTIL THE ELECTION
IN THIS NEWS CYCLE IS RISKY, BY
SATURDAY WE COULD HAVE A NEW
CLOSING ARGUMENT, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, KAVANAUGH WAS JUST TWO
WEEKS AGO.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE BAILING
OUT OF THREE IMPORTANT RACES
TODAY.
DOWN IN TEXAS 23rd, WILL HERD,
THAT WAS A DISTRICT THAT HILLARY
CLINTON WON BUT HE'S PULLING
AHEAD, DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
TAKE MONEY OUT OF THAT, PUT
SCHMIDT WHERE ELSE.
ALSO IN NEBRASKA 2 AND MINNESOTA
8.
PLACES WHERE THE DEMOCRATS THINK
THEY HAVE PICKUPS, THOSE ARE OUT
OF REACH FOR THEM.
POSSIBLY, OF COURSE IT DEPENDS
ON TURNOUT.
IF THEY AREN'T GOING TO PUT
MONEY IN IT SHOWS SOMETHING.
THE DEMOCRATS' CLOSING MESSAGE,
HEALTHCARE, SPECIFICALLY
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS, WHICH
WE CAN TALK ABOUT MORE IF YOU
WANTED.
IF YOU SEE THEIR ADS, THEY'RE
STARTING TO SAY, CHECK ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
VOTE FOR A CHECK ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IF YOU ARE A CHALLENGER TO A
REPUBLICAN IN CONGRESS, THE AD
WOULD SAY, JESSE WATTERS VOTES
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP 98% OF THE
TIME.
YOU DON'T WANT THAT, DO YOU?
THAT'S HOW THEY'RE TRYING TO
MOTIVATE THE BASE.
REPUBLICANS --
>> Jesse: JUST 98%?
>> Dana: WELL THE IF YOU HEDGE A
LITTLE, ON A COUPLE OF THINGS.
REPUBLICANS, YOU SEE THEIR ADS,
IT'S IMMIGRATION, AND SUPPORT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IDEA THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IT REALLY IS.
HE SHOULD EMBRACE IT, BASICALLY,
OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL ALL
WEEKEND.
AND I THINK THAT THE
REPUBLICANS, IF THEY CAN KEEP
FOCUS, A 4R0689 RACES THAT
DEMOCRATS -- A LOT OF THE RACES
DEMOCRATS THOUGHT THEY COULD WIN
WILL BE OUT OF THEIR REACH.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THE MID TERMS, GREG?
>> Greg: I TRY NOT TO THINK
ABOUT IT THAT MUCH.
>> Jesse: IT'S YOUR JOB.
>> Greg: WEEKEND COMING UP,
HAVING FUN.
WHEN YOU WATCH THE RALLY, YOU
KNOW WHAT TRUMP'S MESSAGE IS.
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NATIONAL SECURITY, CRIME,
BORDERS.
IT'S LAW AND ORDER.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE FOR.
YOU ONLY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
AGAINST.
HIM, AND THEY'RE ALSO AGAINST
BEING OUT OF POWER.
THAT LEADS YOU INTO THE ARENA OF
WHAT NANCY PELOSI SAID,
PARTICULARLY LOATHSOME, THAT
COLLATERAL DAMAGE IS ACCEPTABLE.
WE KNOW THIS, WE KNOW THAT THE
END JUSTIFIES THE MEANS BY ANY
MEANS POSSIBLE, THEY NEED THEIR
POWER.
YOU SAW WITH KAVANAUGH, HIS
FAMILY, COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW WITH THE CARAVAN, THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE ARE THOSE
PEOPLE WHO MAY SUFFER GRAVE
INJURY TRYING TO CROSS A RIVER
OR BEING SEXUALLY ABUSED.
THEY WANT THAT SPECTACLE, THEY
WANT THAT.
THAT'S COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES,
INCREASE REGULATION THAT, HURTS
BUSINESSES, COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
YOU GO BACK TO OBAMACARE,
COLLATERAL DAMAGE, YOU LOST YOUR
DOCTOR, YOUR RATES WENT UP.
THAT WAS COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
BECAUSE THE IDEA OF GOVERNMENT
RUNNING HEALTHCARE, SUCH A BIG
IDEA, DIDN'T MATTER IF YOU LOST
YOUR DOCTOR.
THEIR MESSAGE, IT'S NOT ABOUT
IDEAS, NOT ABOUT PROGRESS, IT'S
ABOUT POWER BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT IDEOLOGY,
THAT MEANS COLLATERAL DAMAGE IS
NOT JUST ACCEPTABLE, IT'S
PRACTICALLY THE ONLY THING YOU
HAVE, THEY'RE NOT DEMOCRATS,
THEY'RE DAMAGE-CATS.
>> Jesse: OH, JUAN.
YOU RESPOND TOO THAT.
>> Juan: THE SHOCKING POINT IS
THAT REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE A
MESSAGE RIGHT NOW.
THE PRESIDENT COMES OUT AND SAYS
THE MESSAGE IS KAVANAUGH AND
CARAVAN.
HE COULD HAVE THROWN IN THERE
KAEPERNICK AND KANYE, JUST GO
FULL RAPPER.
>> Jesse: 3Ks, 4Ks.
>> Juan: HE'S STRUGGLING WITH
THE ABSENCE OF A MESSAGE.
LOOK AT THE ADVERTISING PUT ON
THE AIR, EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO BE ALL ABOUT TAX
CUTS FOR THE REPUBLICANS, WE
DELIVERED ON THE TAX CUT TO THE
FORGOTTEN MAN.
WHAT YOU SEE IS REPUBLICANS ARE
NOT RUNNING COMMERCIALS ABOUT
TAX CUTS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
HAVING ANY TRACTION WITH THE
VOTERS.
SO THAT MEANS YOU GO BACK TO RED
MEAT, YOU GO BACK TO THE MOST
KIND OF CULTURAL WAR ISSUES YOU
CAN FIND.
FOR TRUMP, YOU KNOW, HIS NUMBER
ONE HIT ON THE ROAD IS ALWAYS
IMMIGRATION, BUILD THE WALL, GO
AFTER 'EM.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S TRYING TO
DO.
TRYING TO GET HIS BASE REVVED UP
FOR THE MID TERMS, WITH THESE
RED MEAT ISSUES.
IT'S SO FAR THAT THE BIG ABSENCE
IS THAT REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE A
STRONG MESSAGE.
WHEN THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO HAVE A MESSAGE.
I TELL YOU --
>> Jesse: THE ECONOMY.
>> Juan: EVEN ON THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE, AT THE WHITE HOUSE
THEY'RE HAVING BIG FIGHTS
BETWEEN JOHN BOLTEN AND JOHN
KELLER, CHIEF -- KELLY, WITH THE
RHETORIC, A SPIKE, MEAN MANY
COMING AND CROSSING.
THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT POLICY WOULD BE AT THE
KWHOUS.
BUT THEY WANT TO SAY -- AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY WANT TO SAY IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS.
TRUMP SAYS IT'S THE DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE PAYING TO HAVE THE
CARAVAN COME, JESSE.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS, ABSURD, BUT
I GUESS SOME PEOPLE MIGHT BE
SUCKERS OUT THERE AND BUY THAT
FOOLISHNESS.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE ARE GOING DOWN
THERE FROM AMERICA TO HELP THE
CARAVAN COME NORTH.
>> Juan: OH, COME ON.
>> Jesse: THAT'S IN AN ARTICLE,
I'LL SHOW YOU.
BEFORE WE GET TO KENNEDY, I WANT
TO ADDRESS THE TAX CUTS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY TAX CUTS.
WHEN HE SAYS JOBS, WHEN HE SAYS
THE ECONOMY, WHEN HE SAYS GDP,
THAT'S UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
EVERYTHING HE'S DONE
ECONOMICALLY.
THAT'S INCLUDING GETTING ACROSS.
>> Juan: DOES THAT INCLUDE DRIVE
UP THE DEFICIT 17% IN ONE YEAR?
>> Dana: THAT IS LAUGHABLE, A
DEMOCRAT TALKING ABOUT THE
DEFICIT.
>> Juan: REPUBLICANS SAYING
DEFICITS DON'T WATER BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS AREN'T IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> Jesse: THE U.S. IS COMING
FROM THE LEFT.
>> AS OON INDEPENDENT VOTER AND
WOMAN WHO DOESN'T FIT NEATLY
INTO ANY CATEGORY OR BOX I LOOK
AT FREEDOM-KILLING DEFICIT
SPENDING AND IT IS ATROCIOUS.
FROM BOTH PARTIES.
THEY'RE SO SIMILAR IN THAT
REGARD, IT REALLY IS, THIS IS A
THING THAT IS GOING TO HAMSTRING
GENERATIONS AND CURTAIL ECONOMIC
MOBILITY, WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR
THINGS LIKE HIRING NEW EMPLOYEES
AND GOING OUT AND SPENDING
MONEY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT CONSUMER
OPTIMISM, ONE OF THE BIG DRIVERS
FOR THE ECONOMY, AND FOR THE
STOCK MARKET, THAT IS COMPLETELY
STIFLED WHEN WE FINALLY GET THE
BILL FOR THIS OUTRAGEOUS MONEY
THAT WE'RE SPENDING ON
EVERYTHING.
AND NO ONE, PAUL RYAN CAME INTO
POWER AS THIS WONKY SPENDING,
YOU KNOW, HE WAS A PERSON OF
NEUTRALIZED SPENDING AND TALKED
ABOUT CUTTING COSTS.
AND THE DEBT IS NOW $21
TRILLION.
WHEN NANCY PELOSI GOES OUT, AND
WHEN SHE IS THE MOUTHPIECE FOR
THIS PARTY, WHEN SHE TALKS ABOUT
THE HOUSE IS GOING TO ONCE AGAIN
REST IN DEMOCRAT HANDS, THAT
RILES UP REPUBLICANS MORE THAN
ANYTHING, AND INDEPENDENTS,
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT A LIKABLE
PERSON.
SHE'S NOT ONLY UNLIKABLE, SHE'S
A PERSON WHO DOESN'T HAVE A
MESSAGE.
YOU CAN JOKE THAT REPUBLICANS
DON'T HAVE A MESSAGE, AND YOU
MAY NOT AGREE WITH IT, BUT
SOMETHING IS SIMPLE, AS JOBS NOT
MOBS THAT, RESONATES.
PEOPLE WOULD MUCH RATHER HAVE
JOBS AND MONEY FOR THEIR KIDS
THAN RUN UP AGAINST A WALL OF
PROTESTERS WHO ARE GOING TO CALL
THEM NAMES AND SPIT ON THEM AND
STOP THEIR CAR AND VANDALIZE
NICE CITIES.
>> Greg: COREY BOOKER, WE
SKIPPED OVER IT, HE SAID CANADA
IS MORE AMERICAN.
IS HE AWARE THEY DON'T HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT?
HE SHOULD LOOK IT UP.
THEIR FREEDOM OF SPEECH IN
CANADA IS NOT ABSOLUTE.
THEIR GOVERNMENT CAN PASS LAWS
THAT THEY FEEL ARE REASONABLE TO
LIMIT YOUR SPEECH.
HE SHOULD PROBABLY TAKE THAT.
>> TRUDEAU, TRUE DAT.
>> Jesse: SPARTA KAS WANTS TO
RUN ON CANADA FIRST, LET HIM.
>> Juan: PELOSI ISN'T POPULAR
WITH REPUBLICANS, THEY CAN USE
HER IN THE ADS.
MITCH McCONNELL SAYING IF THE
REPUBLICANS GET -- RETAIN
CONTROL WE'RE GOING AFTER SOCIAL